So we were spending a couple classes these days learning basic facts and
vocabulary about finance.
And uh,
along the way we're trying to apply the simple lessons that Irving Fisher taught
about,
uh,
turning a financial problem into a general equilibrium problem and making use in
particular of the budget set.
You know,
that very simple budgets that we wrote down at the very beginning.
It turns out to be quite useful and people often can get quite confused.
So the last issue we ended with,
I'm going to take up again.
Suppose that you've got a very long lived institution like Yale.
Um,
how should Yale think of how much to spend every year?
What is Yale's budget set?
Well,
you know,
almost every big institution like Yale creates a fiction of an annual budget and
they talk about the deficit and having to bring the deficit under control and
making cuts to,
you know,
close the deficit gap.
But really there is no such thing as a,
as a one year budget said.
I mean,
why one year?
Why not one month?
Why not one day?
Nobody expects Yale to budget balance its budget every day.
Some expenditure comes in in the day.
They have to hire an electrician to fix something unexpected.
They're going to spend more money than they take in,
in a student,
uh,
tuition that day.
So the fact that they're supposed to budget the balance every year is just a
fiction.
Irving Fisher taught us that Yale really has,
if you can borrow and lend and you don't have to worry about risk,
there's one infinite lived budget set.
It's an infinite horizon budget set where you just take the present value of all
the expenditures.
That's the,
that's the left hand side and the present value of all the revenue that's the
right hand side,
and make sure that the left hand side is smaller than the right hand side over
the whole course of Yale's life.
So that simple principle has a tremendous implication,
which was overlooked to the Chagrin of the last deal president.
So as I said,
the issue was in 1997 I believe it could have been 96,
something like that.
1997,
uh,
Benno Schmidt,
who was then the Yale president,
released a white paper.
He called it documenting the fact that Yale hadn't,
uh,
had deferred maintenance in the buildings he called it.
And the,
a study that he commissioned,
a very good study that he commissioned,
argued that the deferred maintenance Yale could be brought up to snuff and then
go on afterwards as a normal running institution provided it spent $100 million
a year for 10 years,
and that included fixing every college,
you know,
they're going to do more than one a year over a 10 year period.
So Yale's total budget,
as I told you,
it was about a billion dollars at the time.
And then here all of a sudden was this hundred million dollars a year expense
for 10 years.
That's 10% of the Yale budget.
And a lot of the costs,
you know,
you can't change.
I mean,
you have to have the lights on,
you have to heat the buildings.
You can't really reduce those costs.
So Benno Schmidt came to the conclusion that he have to reduce the costs.
He could change by 15% in order to balance the budget to cut,
you know,
about a hundred million dollars a year out of the budget.
So he announced one day that he's going to fire 15% of the faculty by attrition
you don't,
if they were junior faculty wouldn't promote them.
And if they were senior faculty,
wait till they retired and not replace them.
So this needless to say,
caused a tremendous commotion of knowing the Faculty.
And as I told you,
a committee was formed and,
and I had to present the report.
So actually the report when pretty carefully through all the calculations made
in the white paper,
but the heart of the report was simply to reel to apply the lesson of Irving
Fisher.
So what is the lesson of Irving Fisher?
Let's suppose that there's no inflation so that when they say $100 million a
year,
they mean a hundred million real dollars a year.
So Irving Fisher would say Yale's going to live forever.
Let's suppose that we want that.
Yale wants the same quality of education every year forever.
So should have the same wheel spending every year forever after,
after it compensates for inflation.
So at the moment we're assuming there's no inflation.
So what does that mean?
That means that you just look at the right hand side and you say what's Yale's
revenue?
Well,
whatever it was before we've,
we were told by this report to the president that as long as you did the
deferred maintenance,
yeah.
Would be back in balance.
So what's the loss of revenue on the right hand side?
It's 10 years of $100 million a year.
As you can see now you need a,
uh,
an interest rate.
What should the interest rate be?
Well,
uh,
should it be the nominal interest rate of the real interest rate?
What we're supposing now there's no inflation.
So it should be the real interest rate because all the hundreds are,
are,
you know,
have no inflation in them.
So what real interest rate should we use?
Well,
the,
yeah,
the white paper used 5% because they thought that was the number that Yale
could,
uh,
earn after inflation pretty reliably.
Every year they call it.
They think that's the,
the real rate of return Yale gets.
And so they discounted at 5%.
Now the real rate of interest typically in the economy is 3% but let's suppose
that we calculated this at 5%.
The present value of a a hundred for 10 years is 772.
Now,
how could you do that in your head?
Well,
we know that,
you know,
5% is going to double every,
um,
uh,
14 years,
you know,
five and the 72 is about 14.
So in 10 years,
you're going to get,
if a doubles every 14 years,
10 years is going to be less than half the value of the bond.
So if you've got a hundred forever,
at 5% interest,
that would be 2 billion.
And we know for only 10 years,
it's less than half the value.
So you know,
considerably less than half the value.
So it's not 1 billion.
It's something less than that at 772.
So I just did that in excel and I calculated seven 72.
But in your head,
you know that if it had gone on for 14 years,
then the present value,
our formula or famous formula is that you would take the coupon,
a hundred divided by the interest rate 0.05 times one minus one plus r to the
10th.
And so we know that if,
if this were 14 instead of 10 you'd get a half here.
So this is 20 times 100 which is 2 billion times a half would be 1 billion.
But since it's only 10 years and not 14 years,
it's less than a billion.
So okay,
772 so when you're ahead,
you could have probably figured that out.
So the loss in pres approximately.
So you can be sitting there in the audience hearing Benno Schmidt talk and be
computing in your head that we're talking about something under a billion,
like you know,
three quarters of a billion.
So now how much does that mean reduction in every year?
Well,
if he yells going to spend the same amount every year,
that means it should be spending 5% of 772 less every year.
That's 38 point $6 million less every year.
So that's a drastically smaller number than a hundred million dollars a year.
It's crazy just to think that because you've got these expenditures for 10 years
and the no expenditures after that,
that you should cut the budget by 100 million and then let it go up after 10
years.
So,
um,
you'd only need to cut it by 38 million.
Now,
by the way,
5% is a pretty arbitrary number.
Suppose you put 3% here,
well,
3% would give you a much higher present value,
but then when you multiplied by 3% at the end for the,
for the annual reduction,
it would give you a much smaller number.
So that anyway,
this number,
uh,
which I computed an XL,
but again,
you can do it sort of in your head is 853 million,
but you multiply that by 3% and you get 25 or 26 million a year.
So now the reduction is starting to sound like it's not such a,
a frightening thing.
So let's stick with the,
let's stick with the 5% which is what the white paper,
take all of the assumptions of the white paper and take it literally,
and then notice that they never said anything about inflation.
So actually this,
uh,
this calculation of present value loss is,
is,
uh,
it's right,
it's,
um,
there's inflation and save.
The inflation at that time was around 4%.
In fact,
all the Gail contracts that are still in place assume a 4% inflation,
even though inflation is less than that now.
But anyway,
so that 100 million a year of dollars is actually less in present value terms.
Because what should discount by,
if you look at the present value of $100 million over 10 years,
and you take into account installers,
you should be discounting by the real interest rate times the inflation.
Okay?
So by 9%,
a little,
a overnight,
tiny bit over 9%.
So if you discount that by 9%,
you get a 641 billion as the present value.
1 million as the present value loss to Yale.
Okay?
Now,
given that there's inflation,
how much should you be spending every year?
Okay,
you should be spending in real dollars reducing your spend.
A sure how much in real dollars?
Well,
by five not oh wait,
9% by 5% of the 641 million.
So if you have 641 that's today's present value in,
you know,
there hasn't been any inflation yet.
So that's the real loss in dollars.
So if you ask what's the real expenditure reduction every year,
it's 5% of 641 and that's 32 million.
Okay.
So 32 million is a far smaller number than 100 million and requires a small,
far smaller drop in Expat in you know,
expenses.
So our committee recommended that we cut the faculty by 6% instead of by 15% and
6% there are a lot of people leaving every year.
You can do 6% pretty quickly.
So the upshot of this is that it's a simple application of present value,
very elementary calculation.
It came as somewhat of a revelation to our administrators,
I'm afraid.
And,
uh,
the day after the report,
the provost of the university resigned.
Two weeks later,
the dean of the university resigned and two months later,
the president of the university resigned and Rick Levin,
the current president took over and he,
um,
cut the faculty by 6%,
but by no more than that.
And then of course,
the,
the finances of yeah,
got much better and he's since added back that 6% plus a little bit more than
that.
So just to tell you though,
something good about the Yale administration,
the provost who resigned that next day happens to be a friend of mine.
I've had dinner with him every month for the last,
you know,
12 years since this happened.
And he's never once criticized me or showing the slightest discomfort about the
report that basically ended his,
uh,
his,
you know,
his administrative career.
He cares so much about Yale and is so d was so determined to do the right thing.
He just thought he made a miscalculation and stepped aside.
So he,
he,
so I believe that he wanted to do the right thing for Yale and just made the
wrong calculation.
Not that he had some political agenda or something to cut such a huge part of
the faculty.
So it's the most honest and the most,
uh,
um,
Yale loving,
uh,
administrator that,
um,
you could imagine.
And,
um,
I didn't know what the reaction would be if someone like him after giving the
report.
I was quite terrified actually,
that they'd be,
they were still the president and the provost and the dean,
that they would be quite angry at our committee.
Um,
but they responded,
um,
with tremendous integrity.
Yes.
Okay.
You tell me why did I do that?
So why,
so someone else tell me.
So that's a good question.
Why is that?
Yes.
Finding that Cubana the perpetuity that with a 5% interest,
it's like you're,
you're rearranging.
See over articles,
present value,
present value times,
right?
So the question was why?
After I figured out the present value loss,
I like a 772 million.
Why did I multiply that by 5% to figure out how much Yale should reduce it
spending every year?
And the answer that was given down here is that I'm assuming that Yale was going
to go on forever.
So Yale can reduce his expenditures every year forever.
And by doing that and make up for the same present value loss,
so,
uh,
forever means perpetually.
So it's a perpetuity.
So how much do you have to reduce,
what is the coupon reduction,
the expenditure reduction every year at 5% interest,
that just makes a present value decline of 772 million?
Well,
it's 5% of the principal.
If you have 772 million in the bank,
and every year 5% of that you throw away,
you've thrown away the whole value.
Oh,
at 5% interest of the 772 million.
So by reducing our expenditures by 5% every year you,
you defray the $772 million loss.
So that's the credit.
So the critical thing,
the critical mistake that the administration made is they had a short run
problem with a bunch of short run costs,
but Yale is going to live forever and Yale should,
should share the cost and the loss overall future,
uh,
generations not just make the current faculty and the current students and the
current,
you know,
city bear,
all the costs of,
of,
uh,
of this one shot a loss,
the,
you know,
one shot problem that Yale faced.
So they weren't thinking in fishers terms of taking the present value over the
whole course of the lifetime of the institution.
They were thinking,
well,
we've got to spend $100 million this year.
We better cut costs by $100 million.
But you,
but that's obviously crazy.
Like suppose you had to spend an extra,
you know,
$100,000 in one day,
uh,
does that mean you should,
you know,
lay off your faculty for one days?
You can find the money to,
to pay that.
And of course not.
So you have to you to spread the loss over the lifetime of the university.
Okay.
So there are any other questions about this principle?
Yes,
77 million.
If I want it to incur the whole cost over over 10 years,
then I would have to reduce my expenditures by $100 million a year for if,
if at the end of 10 years I wanted to be back.
Even then I would have to spend less,
I would have to cut my expenditures by exactly the money I was pouring into the
buildings.
So if I wanted to,
you know,
reduce my expenditures by an equal amount every year,
I'd have to be $100 million for 10 years.
Right.
If the horizons or if the,
if the the maintenance costs go over a pen,
10 year period and I want the expenditures to go over a 10 year period.
Okay.
Right.
So if I want the expenditures to reduced evenly over 10 year period,
I'd have to do $100 million a year if I wanted to eat away the cost all in one
year.
I guess I didn't understand your question.
You're saying if I wanted to reduce expenditures entirely in one year and then
return next year to my usual pattern of expenditure,
then I'd have to cut the $1 billion budget by 772 million.
So that would involve basically firing the whole faculty and saying,
take a year off.
You're on furlough,
sort of what they're doing in California.
So yes.
Yeah,
I could do that.
If I wanted,
I could rearrange the hundred million anywhere I want any way I want it to.
So you would cut less than a hundred million dollars this year out of the budget
and a little bit more every year after that.
Well,
one way to do the costs over within a 10 year timeframe is reduce costs,
reduce,
you know,
paying the faculty by $100 million every year for 10 years.
Right.
That would obviously do it because that's the money I need to get.
You could rearrange that by reducing costs a little less at the beginning and a
little more at the end of the 10 years.
But I would say that doesn't sound no one,
you know,
why do that then that makes the,
that's kind of what bad politicians do.
They say,
well we're not gonna,
you know,
it's not our fault.
We'll just make those guys and year 10 get totally crushed and sooner,
pretty soon they are in year 10 and then they've got,
you know,
200 million,
they have to cut costs and that,
yes.
So
do another round.
Right.
Okay.
So there's a good question.
So there,
there,
there was actually some people that,
you know,
the administrator that was their best response,
they said,
well even though the white paper said this was a one shot thing and after we can
do this 10 year prank plan,
Yale is back in good shape.
And of course every year or Gail has allowed,
you know,
maintenance expenses.
That's part of the budget is maintenance.
And so after we get the buildings back and ship,
you know,
tip top shape,
we're going to keep them in tip top shape by doing these,
uh,
you know,
normal expenditures every year.
So we should never have another period where you have to do something drastic
like that.
That's what the white paper said.
But after the report,
they responded just like you said.
They said,
well,
we didn't really mean that maybe in 25 years we're going to have to do another
remodeling a effort.
And so well,
if you need it to do that,
then,
uh,
it wasn't just,
you know,
a onetime deferred maintenance,
it means that you've grasped,
drastically underestimated the costs of keeping up the buildings over,
you know,
over the els whole future.
And then you would have to then it wouldn't be,
so then you would have these reductions and expenditures for the first 10 years,
and then,
you know,
when you're 35,
you'd have to have more reductions.
And then in year 70 you'd have more reductions like that.
So you have to take the present value of all of those things and then figure out
how much to reduce expenditures on an even basis.
And so it would be much more than 32 million that would,
you know,
be 60 or something million or 50 million.
So you're exactly right,
but that's not what they said.
And the white paper,
you know,
so I took them literally what they meant.
And,
um,
so what happened after that?
You know,
Yale has done much more building expenditures than that,
but that's because Yale's endowment went up to 23 billion.
You also from 3 billion,
which it was at the time,
it's now 23 billion.
So Gail's launched an incredible program of building construction.
Basically,
they've done two things.
They've hired a huge number of,
uh,
built a huge number of construction jobs and they've hired a lot,
a lot of administrators and stuff.
So what the faculty is still not that much bigger,
you know,
went down 6%.
It's now back a little bigger than it was before.
So,
you know,
the plan to expand the college and expand the faculty hasn't happened yet.
So Yale faces another choice now,
you know,
the endowment went to 23 billion,
and then this past year are they managed to lose down to 17 billion,
you know,
30% got Wass and we're down to 17 billion now.
So again,
we have the same question.
We just lost $6 billion.
How much should we reduce,
uh,
expenditures every year?
So what's your answer to that?
Not 30%.
What a,
yeah.
So how much would you do some expenditures?
Well,
why wouldn't it be 30%?
Because Yale spends a lot of money.
It doesn't get from the endowment,
right?
It gets money from tuition for example.
So yeah.
Okay.
So how much would you,
yeah,
so what should yell do?
What do you think he is going to have to take out of the budget now?
Yeah.
And let's say it's still 5% real in truth,
then what would you do?
Yeah,
you're fine.
Yeah.
So what's that
times 0.05.
So what's that?
Hard to do these things in your head.
Right?
But what is it?
Okay,
300 million.
So Yale's got to somehow cut 300 million out of its budget.
And um,
so it's not going to do it in one year,
but over the course of the next few years it's going to have to cut 300 million.
Now the budget is well over 2 billion.
So that's 15% of the budget though.
Yells going to have to cut.
So this is a serious thing.
How do you cut 15% of the Yale budget?
Yeah.
What firing faculty?
Well,
I hope they don't do,
I think they learned their lesson and so I doubt if they'll do that.
But there it's uh,
you know,
things were already changing their charging for long distance telephone calls
and you know,
all kinds of stuff like that,
but it doesn't get you quite 300 million,
but there's going to be a bunch of stuff like that.
So anyway,
we have another budget problem by the way.
So these kinds of budget problems are happening all over the country.
I gave a talk at Albany University and they're going to,
they're going to abolish their graduate economics program.
Um,
Suny Albany,
that's,
you know,
so they're doing all,
these are serious problems losing that much money.
But in any case,
6 billion translates to,
right.
The difference here is 6 billion and you multiply that by 0.05 just as we said,
and that equals 300 million a year.
So yeah,
won't do it right away.
But over the course of,
you know,
a few years,
the ales going to have to reduce its budget by 300 million.
So they're going to obviously choose to do a lot less building and sell Volvo's
those.
Presumably some of the new people that get hot got hired,
they're going to not keep.
So,
okay.
Any other questions?
Yup.
Yes.
Excellent assumption.
Right.
Okay.
Very good question.
So in the front he's saying,
you know,
this presumes that we know for sure that the endowment lost 6 billion,
it will never recover it.
Um,
maybe that's a temporary drop in the stock market and I'll go back up and
basically the principal,
he's applying as he's saying,
you can't make these drastic reductions in the annual expenditures,
you know,
firing people.
And then two years later realizing you've got a lot of money trying to hire them
back cause you won't be able to hire them back.
So clearly Yale has to have a more complicated rule about how it gradually
adjust its spending when there's a change in the endowment.
And so we're going to talk about that later cause it involves uncertainty and
how to think about uncertainty.
But you're absolutely right.
The Yale,
Yale will not.
So Levan did not announce a $300 million reduction immediately,
but he's announced a big reduction immediately and you know,
you can expect next year if the stock market doesn't drastically improve for
there to be another reduction.
And by the way,
you know this number could go down as well as it goes up.
So we're going to come back to Yale's investments and you know what they're like
a lot of Gayle's investments are called private equity investments that are very
hard to value.
So for all we know all this 17 is a lot worse than that.
Um,
but we'll be finding out,
uh,
in the next year or two.
It's not like a hedge fund where you have to,
you know,
value all your assets by what the market will be willing to pay a lot of these
assets there.
There is no market,
so they just sort of make up with the number is.
So we have to wait and we're going to come back and discuss this.
It's a very interesting question.
Okay.
All right.
So one last thing about this present value calculations.
One last obvious thing.
It's hard to keep in your mind the difference between real and nominal.
Okay?
Okay,
so let's just do a very simple thing.
The mortgage mortgages
are traditionally nominal pain,
traditionally nominal fixed payments,
so you might pay,
okay?
So for example,
$100,000,
$100,000 30 year mortgage at 2.3% is about $4,600 per year.
How did I do that so quickly in my head?
Well,
because I know if the interest rate is 2.3% and you're going to pay it forever,
you'd pay 2,300 a year.
We know at 30 years at 2.3% 2.3% doubles almost in 30 years.
That's 69 that's getting pretty close to 72 so maybe it takes 31 years or
something to double.
So after 30 years,
the remaining part of the mortgage is only,
you know,
the remainder,
the remainder is worth half the mortgage.
So you've lost half of the value by only getting it for 30 years.
So instead of paying 2,300 you have to pay 4,600 you know,
so the coupon over 0.023 times one minus 1.0 to three to the 30th okay,
that's,
that's one minus a half about,
so it's self,
this coupon equals 100,000
the payment is going to be,
since this is a half,
the payment isn't going to be,
you know,
2,300 has to be twice that 4,600 okay.
So it's 4,600 per year.
So if there's no inflation,
that means you're making the same wheel payment every year.
Now what happens if there's inflation?
What if inflation goes up?
What if inflation goes up
and now what's going to happen to what you have to pay?
Well this is just,
okay,
how would you figure that out?
Well,
if inflation is you know,
another 2.3% or something,
then he would pay then the nominal interest rate one plus cy is going to equal
the real interest rate times the nominal interest rate times the rate of
inflation.
Okay,
so let's say this is 1.023 and this is also 1.0 to three so that's 1.04 little
bit more than four six almost,
you know,
a little bit more than four six so you know that the interest rate,
the mortgage companies are now going to charge is going to be a 1.046 s so the
4.6 it's going to be the,
the the mortgage interest rate.
And so you can figure out by the same calculation
what,
what the coupon is going to be.
So what's the coupon going to be?
Okay,
well if you're,
you know,
instead of doubling every 30 years at 4.6% it's going to double approximately
every 15 years.
So this is going to be doubling twice.
This is a quarter.
So this will be three quarters here.
And so if you multiply,
you know,
everything,
2,300 a year and times.
MMM.
2,300 a year times four thirds.
Okay.
Right.
Doing the right calculation here,
I'm telling you,
so it's so easy to compute in your head.
I mean,
well and
Oh,
I forgot to change this to 46 so the interest rate is four six.
Okay.
So you multiply fourth that,
so if you multiply,
so of this to the other side is 4,600 times four thirds.
Okay.
And that's,
you know,
6,000 about.
Okay.
So that the annual payment is going to go up to 6,000 instead of 4,600 was 4,600
the interest rate went up because there was inflation.
So of course they're going to ask you for more money every year because if you
paid the same amount every year,
and this is the real payment.
Yeah,
okay.
If you make the same amount,
and this is tying in terms of inflation,
correct.
The dollars you're paying less and less every year.
So clearly if you started with no inflation at a number like this,
no inflation,
okay,
so no inflation and now you've got inflation,
but the same real interest rate and the present value of your expenditures,
the present value,
right?
The mortgage company's going to want,
the lender's going to want to get the same amount back in real terms as it got
before because the inflation hasn't changed the real world.
So Irving Fisher would save the inflation is just a veil.
Everybody's going to want the same real interest rate.
And so the mortgage is going to have to return the same real thing it did
before.
The present value in real terms of the real payments is still going to be
100,000 so if the real payments go down over time and have the same present
value they had before,
it's gotta be that they're higher at the beginning and in real terms,
lower at the end.
So sure enough,
6,000 is a much higher number at the beginning than 4,600 so of course when
inflation went up and everybody knows it's up,
that mortgage companies are going to ask for a higher annual payments.
So it'll be 6,000 a year instead of 4,600 a year.
But now if you inflation correct that the 6,000 every year is going to be a
less,
you don't in terms of real goods,
less and less every year.
But the present discounted value of this thing has to be the same as where you
started.
So the effect is the young,
the young borrowers are going to be spending a lot more and real goods when
they're young and a lot less when they're old.
So inflation has an unfortunate impact on mortgages,
quoted a nominal dollars that it makes the repayments happen earlier.
So the young who have less money or having to pay a huge amount and when they
get old,
you know the inflation so high that that same $6,000 is practically nothing.
So when they're 50 and 60 they're paying practically the peanuts to them.
But when they were young,
it was really a hardship.
So there's a big problem with nominal mortgages,
which is that in inflationary times it kills the housing market.
Fortunately,
we're not in an inflationary times.
Okay?
Any questions about that?
All right.
So that's the basic lesson of taking the present value.
And again,
you've always got to sort out the nominal from the real and look through the
veil and don't get all mixed up by the fact that there's inflation.
It's the real thing that you want to concentrate on as much as you can.
Alright,
so,
alright,
so that's it for the obvious lesson of present value.
Now I want to introduce another word,
which is very famous and finance.
It's called the yield or yield to maturity.
And I want to do it unlike the way I've presented in the notes,
I want to do it in terms of a hedge fund.
Okay?
So if you can see this,
okay,
so yield the next topic or yield to maturity is a way of trying to compute one
number that summarizes how good a bond is or how good,
how well on hedge fund has done.
So I think the more interesting case and the less obvious one is to start with a
hedge fund.
Okay.
So now how do you measure how well a hedge funds doing or how well it's done in
the past?
Nevermind.
Yeah,
how well it's done in the past.
We're going to spend a lot of the course talking about this in various ways with
the first way to do it involves yield to maturity.
So let's see why the problem is a little complicated.
So I imagine that they're three investors in this hedge fund.
Okay.
So every year some of the investors are going to decide what to do and they're
going to decide whether to withdraw money yearns and faster one,
maybe he's going to withdraw money.
The hedge funds just beginning,
he's going to put in $100 the other two guys haven't done anything.
Okay.
So now the hedge fund,
before this guy put in his money,
he had nothing.
It's just beginning.
He's put in his hundred dollars.
So they hedge funds got $100 okay,
so that's it.
So I'm imagining,
you know,
these all happen,
they usually happen quarterly or annually or something.
They don't happen every day.
There's a fixed moment at which everyone deposits their money.
So let's say they happen annually.
The guy puts in $100 at the beginning of the year for the rest of the year.
Nobody can do anything.
They can't take money out,
they can't put money in.
So the hedge fund,
let's say,
um,
manages to get put the hundred dollars to work and finds a 7% return.
Okay?
So it's now got the hedge fund altogether has got $107.
So let's just go to the hedge fund altogether.
Uh,
has a hundred,
had a hundred,
the hedge fund had a hundred after these guys,
cause only one guy put in money and now the hedge funds got $107.
Well,
that hundred $7 is all the first guy's money because nobody else has put
anything in.
He still owns it.
Okay.
So,
so far the hedge fund got a 7% return.
Well now the next year.
Okay.
We're now at the beginning of year two.
You know,
our first investor thinks to himself,
well,
you know,
they did find 7% not great,
but you know,
um,
I'm okay,
I'm not going to do anything.
Won't take any money out or put any in a rich second investor puts in a thousand
and another guy puts in 200.
Okay.
So now what's happened to the,
um,
to the Nav of the fund?
Well,
the first guy,
he's,
you know,
at the moment they put in the money.
The first guy still has 107 and his first guy still owns 107 of the dollars.
The second guy now got a thousand in the fund and the third guy's got 200 in the
fund.
And the,
uh,
the hedge fund now has a 1200 plus the 107,
that's 1307.
That's how much money's in the fun.
Okay.
So that's at the beginning of year two.
If you're still following this,
if you're not falling and interrupt me.
Sorry.
I mean,
so what happens in year three in the beginning of the next year,
year three?
Well,
let's say our guy,
oh,
so the fund,
the Hedge Fund makes money and this time it made 3% a crappier,
sorry,
a less good return.
Only 3% of all on film.
I'm glad that's going to live for bus yard anyway.
3% 3% return.
Okay.
And so the,
the hedge fund,
which started at uh,
1307 ended the year at 1307 now by the end of this next year,
it's made 3% on that.
So that's uh,
you know,
it's up to 1346.
Okay.
So,
um,
you know,
$39 3% on 1300 so 1346 now of that,
who's got the money?
Well,
our original guy.
Okay.
He,
he's now made everyone made 3% so his hundred seven turned into 110.
The second guy's got 10 30 in the fund and the third guy's got 206 in the fund.
Okay.
And the total fund is,
you know,
1346.
Now,
let's suppose that our guy,
this is the beginning of year three,
our first guy says 3%.
That's a terrible return.
I'm taking my money out.
I've had it.
It's $110,
you know,
that's what I have.
I'm taking it out,
okay?
So,
and no one else does anything.
So at the end of the year,
you know,
now he's down to zero and everybody else's where they were okay in the hedge
fund thing has gone down a little bit.
Well,
now next year the thing does even worse,
it makes a 0% return.
Okay?
So everybody's money's just the same except that the second guy decides,
you know,
this is really getting lousy.
Uh,
and he takes half his money out.
So this is taking half his money out.
What was his money?
He was,
you know,
1112 and a half of that is five 56 so he takes half of it out,
leaving half behind.
And that reduces,
you know,
in a column on the right,
reduces what the hedge funds,
total caches.
But now the hedge fund is a great year and it makes 50% okay.
And having made 50%
um,
okay.
Yeah.
Anyways,
so then,
oh,
sorry.
So this guy takes half his money out at the beginning of the year,
the fund does badly.
Then the fun,
uh,
I skipped the 8%.
There was an 8% return.
Sorry.
So all want immediate.
Anyway,
Sophie,
uh,
the,
the next year the fund return,
not 0% return 8%.
Okay.
So the first guy,
after the 3% return,
this guy took his money out,
the other guys left it in,
and then the fund had an 8% return.
Okay.
So they are there,
you know,
it's a little bit better,
but this guy decides to take half his money out.
Okay.
And then,
then the fund has a 0% return.
And,
and after that,
this guy decides to take his money out,
half his money out.
But then finally the last year,
the fund gives a 50% return,
which is fantastic.
So all of these guys,
you know,
everybody does well and now let's say they all decide to take their money out.
So now there's nothing left in the fund,
the funds and you know,
they withdrew the total nine 34 okay.
So what I've done here,
just to summarize,
it does,
every people are putting in money or taking out of money at the beginning of the
year,
you can never take out more than you have or you can put money in.
The fund earns returns over the whole year.
And then people again decide to take PE money out or put money in and then the
fun earns a different return the next year and eventually the fun,
you know,
returns all the money or people withdrawal the money.
So the question is,
yeah,
how has the fun dude done?
How would you summarize in one number how the fund has done over?
It's one,
two,
three,
four,
five years of earning returns.
That's the question.
Okay.
So this is a standard,
you know,
this happens every day.
I mean this is obviously what happens every day with hedge funds.
So how do you,
how do hedge funds report how they've done historically?
So do you have any suggestions?
What would you do to summarize how the Hedge Fund has done?
If you had to pick one number,
what would it be?
How would an investor is the fund?
Hmm.
Yeah.
Okay.
So one thing you could do is you could say,
let's say what he said,
literally take,
multiply all these returns.
What does that mean?
That means if you put a dollar in the fund at the beginning,
you learn 7% if you left it there and never took it out,
you get another 3% then you'd get 8% on top of that than 0% then 50% of course
this is a multiplicative thing.
So he says you get 1.07 times 1.038 times 1.08 times one times 1.5 while
deploying all that,
give me the number of dollars you'd have at the end of five years,
given that you put a dollar in in the beginning and never took it out.
And if you want it to annual why's that?
He said,
take the geometric average,
the fifth root of that,
and that's the constant rate of return that would have given you the same amount
of money at the end that you would get by having left a dollar from the
beginning in the fund all the way to the end.
That clear to everybody.
That seems like a logical thing to do.
Okay.
That's what money hedge funds do do.
In fact,
that's the number they tell you.
Now,
why might not that be a great number?
Did everyone follow what his suggestion was?
So by the way,
his number's gonna come out to be,
well,
I don't know.
Anyway,
it's going to be some number we could do that.
Um,
in fact it wouldn't be that hard to do.
Let's just do it.
Um,
oh,
this wasn't a very,
ah,
how about equals?
Oh,
oh dear.
All right.
Okay.
Circular reference.
He calls some,
oh,
why do I have a zero?
Why did I get zero here?
Oh,
cause I'm trying to multiply these ice adding still.
Okay.
So equals I'll just have to do it one by one.
That time's the next one,
times the next one.
There's obviously a much faster way of doing this.
Times the next one,
times that one,
and through.
Okay.
So that's what a dollar would have gotten you if he put it in and kept it to the
end.
And now he's saying,
take this to the fifth power.
So I'll take,
uh,
up,
um,
this point to enter.
Okay,
12.2%.
All right.
Now,
why isn't that the right number?
Why might you think there should be another number?
What's another number?
What's the matter with that way back then?
Okay,
well is it grossly inflated?
But why is it grossly inflated by that?
That's true.
But you've taken that into account.
So the years we didn't do that well,
like the 0% return that got,
that brought the average down.
So why is that a problem?
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's averaging the good years with the bad years.
So,
um,
Yup.
Okay.
That's the crucial thing.
So,
uh,
I didn't do extreme enough numbers,
but let's,
let's,
uh,
the crucial thing to take into account is that,
um,
suppose you have a fund that starts off many funds.
Like my funds started off with very little money,
but we did it at the right time because we,
you know,
we knew that was a good time.
You're going to see when the leverage cycle we talk about,
it was at the bottom of the leverage cycle,
just like this past year,
you know,
we're up 30% this year.
So at the bottom of the leverage cycle,
you're going to have a great year.
Of course,
we hardly had any money because the fund was,
uh,
just starting.
And so we made 50% the first year.
Okay.
But then everybody said,
oh,
these guys must be geniuses.
And they poured a huge amount of money into our fund.
And let's say the next year we did a 10%.
Actually,
we had another great year the second year.
But let's say that we did 10% the second year.
So the young man in the front is saying,
you know,
you made 50 on pennies and then you ate 10% on a gigantic amount of money.
It isn't right to take,
you know,
the average of 50% and 10% because almost all the money that you managed,
you make 10% on not 50% and that's his point.
Okay.
So how would you deal with his point?
How could you figure out a way of computing the right return to compensate for
the fact that some years you have a lot more money at stake then you have love
of years?
Yes.
Yeah.
Take a weighted average.
Well how would you take the weighted average?
Sounds a little complicated.
That's what I'm going to do.
But it's not immediately obvious how to do it.
So anybody,
so I wouldn't have expected you to be able to answer that.
That's you're right on the right track.
So anyone have any thing else to say?
Yup.
Okay.
Um,
all right,
so I'm going,
so I'm going to now give you the answer,
which is a little bit like that.
She's saying do some dollar weighted thing.
And so,
you know,
you,
uh,
somehow weight the numbers by how much money there was invested for that year.
So because it was a lot more money invested in here,
you know,
three than there was in year one,
that number should have somehow have a bigger way.
And uh,
okay.
You know,
it's not exactly clear how the weights are going to get in there,
but that's obvious that that's something like that you ought to do.
So here's the mathematical solution that um,
the internal rate of return or yield,
uh,
gives.
So it says,
let's look every year,
let's look at what happened in the fund.
So you know,
for,
you know,
if we shouldn't care about which investor put in which dollar we care about how
the fund managed dollars,
the name is of the investors don't make any difference.
It's how did the fund manage its money?
So the first year,
the fun got $100.
So as for producing money,
it produced a a negative hundred,
you know,
money went into the fund.
That was the one guy invested.
We don't care who it was.
The total that went into the fund was a hundred the sag it year 1200 went into
the fund.
Those are the second two guys.
The third year,
110 came out.
That was the first guy.
The the fourth year 556 came out.
That was the second guy.
The third,
the f the,
this is the beginning of a fifth year.
The third guy took out $155 and then the last year the second and third guys
took out everything that was left.
So from the point of view of money creation and use,
this is every year.
What went into the fond and what came out of the fund?
The net inflow out.
Okay,
so there are a bunch of numbers.
Now
the question is,
so the,
the one number summary is what rate of return,
it's called the internal rate of return,
which if you discounted all of these numbers,
what would Fisher say if you discounted all of these numbers?
Fish.
If you had,
if you had to use just one interest rate,
Fisher would say,
these kids,
what's the present value of these cash flows?
Will,
if the interest rate was zero,
you just add up all the numbers and you're going to get a big positive.
If the interest rate is infinity,
then that means that the,
the,
you know,
after the first year you're discounting everything to zero and you're going to
get negative 100 so you could say,
what interest rate could you discount all the cash flows at to produce zero.
That would be like saying at that interest rate,
all the fund has done is rearranged.
It's money,
it's taken money in and put money out.
But at that same constant interest rate,
the present value is zero.
So it's basically,
it's allowed you to trade money across periods at this internal rate of return.
The interest rate,
which makes the present value zero.
So if you guessed,
if you guessed,
uh,
so 10% turns out to be the right number.
So if you discounted things by 10%,
you would take and see what the formula is.
You take the inflow and you discount it by 1.1 to the first power and this huge
discount by one oh 1.1 to the second power this.
But you know the inflow,
the net outflow I guess which is 110 you discount by the third,
you know,
1.1 to the third power,
et cetera.
You keep discounting by that.
Okay.
And you get all the discounted net flows,
you add them all up and you'd get practically nothing that's adding them up.
And this is taking the square and I use solver to figure out what the right
discount,
wait,
wait was to make all the zero.
So that's the,
that's the simple way of averaging,
you know,
dollar waiting,
everything you,
you,
you don't care about who the people are,
you don't care about,
uh,
whether one guy's putting money in,
another guy's taking it out at the same time,
he just care about the net.
And you've got a bunch of net numbers.
That's the net outflow and you're trying to say,
what's the one,
what's the single rate of return?
The idea is to say at what interest rate,
if you,
if there were a bank paying an interest rate and all those things discounted,
gave you zero,
that would be like saying the fund is functioning just like a bank,
no matter when people put the money in or take it out,
they're always getting this rate of return,
which is 10% okay,
so they're getting a constant 10% rate of return no matter when the money goes
in or out.
And that's kind of gives you a measure of how well the fund is doing.
Okay,
so that's the internal rate of return it says,
or the yield to maturity.
It says take the net cash flows every year,
find the number,
which when you discount at that number,
you get present value equal to zero.
Okay?
Okay,
so it's 10% which is a different number from 12% now before we got the geometric
average of 12% now very typically,
this is the case that this internal rate of return is lower than the,
you know,
dollar return from putting the money in at the beginning.
Assuming the fund doesn't just collapse and go to zero at the end.
So why is that?
For funds that have survived,
typically that number 12% is higher than 10% why would that be
okay?
What does that tell you about the world?
Oh,
someone who hasn't the while you go ahead.
Yeah.
It tells you that and why and how is it that the hedge fund,
okay.
Could tell you that it tells you that the hedge funds are doing better when they
have a smaller amount of money that when they have a larger amount of money.
Exactly.
You've concluded that it's easier to make money when you have a small amount.
What's another possible explanation?
Yup.
Right.
I think that's the reason.
The reason is that people pour money into hedge funds just after they've done
incredibly well and they keep pouring money and then eventually there was a
blowup.
And so when the blog comes,
the hedge funds have zillions of dollars and they're,
you know,
they're losing a lot of money,
losing a lot of money.
And then,
you know,
then everybody pulls their money out and that's when the cycle is going up and
all of a sudden the hedge funds have these huge returns again,
but they hardly have any money.
So.
Okay.
Any other questions about this?
All right.
So internal rate of return is the way to uh,
is a way we're going to see that as many shortcomings,
but it's a way at getting at the idea as several of you have said that you can't
just take the geometric average,
which is what every hedge fund like ours always produces.
That's the number we tell everybody because it's a better number than the other
one.
So the internal rate of the,
the,
the geometric average of the returns are,
if you're an investor who puts a dollar in at the beginning and leaves it there
forever,
you know,
what's your g,
your geometric average of all your returns.
That's not a good reflection of how the hedge fund's done necessarily because
some years the fund had a lot of money to work with.
And so the average dollar didn't do that well.
And now there's a question about how should you measure the average dollar.
And I've given the internal rate of return.
There are actually other formulas you could give.
This one isn't,
this is the most famous one.
Okay.
So,
um,
all right.
Now let's see how this internal rate of return is used all the time on Wall
Street.
Okay?
By the way,
if you're not following what I'm saying,
you should,
uh,
please interrupt me.
Okay?
So what if you took a bond,
a simple coupon bond?
Okay,
well,
a simple coupon bond.
What does a simple coupon bond,
the yield to maturity of a simple coupon bond.
I'm now on this lecture called yield.
What is the simple coupon bond is simple coupon bond pays the same coupon every
year and then pays the and the coupon at its maturity.
So the yield to maturity is going to be the price which was like a negative
payment.
Okay.
Such that if you,
so if you knew the price,
suppose you,
sorry.
Suppose you knew the price of this bond.
If you knew the price of the bond.
Okay.
And so the bond is promising all these payments,
how good a deal is that?
Well how good a deal it is they would say is you simply take this first negative
payment and all these positive payments and find the unique interest rate,
which when you discount it will give you present value of zero.
And so if this is a coupon bond,
say paying 7% you know,
say the face is a hundred and pay $7 forever and 107 at the end and the price is
105 what do you think the yield to maturity is going to be?
Is it going to be or can you say anything qualitative about it?
Suppose it's a 7% coupon bond face of 110 year bond.
No one thinks that it'll default,
but it's price is 105 what is the yield to maturity in that case?
Do you suppose?
It's just vague.
Guess I just want to qualitative
number
6.7 okay,
that's qualitatively wrong.
Okay,
well maybe it's not qualitatively wrong.
No,
it's qualitatively right.
It's just not okay.
It could have been better,
but okay,
so he's right.
So what,
so what if the PR,
what if the price were a hundred what would the yield to maturity?
B,
7% that's obvious,
right?
So if the price of the bond,
if it's a 7% coupon bond on principle on face of a hundred and it's price is a
hundred price equal to the face,
and obviously the thing that discounts you back to a hundred is going to be 7%
interest.
So if the price were a hundred the yield of maturity would just be 7% but I told
you the price was 105 which is a lot more expensive.
So it's a bad deal.
So it's not going to be as good as 107 so it's not going to be 7% and he said
6.7 okay.
So I think it would be a little worse than that,
but that's qualitatively just what I asked for something worse than 7%
okay.
So who said 6.7% you did.
Okay.
So
Yup.
That's okay.
So that's another number.
Okay.
That's called.
So,
okay,
so let's,
let's cut.
Okay,
so does it,
okay,
so I'm going to come back to your question.
So good question.
So do you see that the price,
do you all see that if you measured the yield to maturity on this bond?
Okay,
the ultimate saw the bond,
remember pays seven seven seven 107 k and its price is 105
okay?
Okay.
So the yield to maturity is going to be that number such that 105 equals seven
over one plus the yield plus seven over one plus the yield squared plus seven
over one plus the yield cubed plus hundred seven over one plus yield to the 10th
okay,
that's 105 so what we observed is that why has to be less than 7%
because if why were exactly equal to 7% this would give us a hundred but this
bond is more expensive.
So you're paying more to get the same payments.
You would then the face,
you're paying more than the face to get the same payment.
If the price were equal to the face,
it would be a 7% yield.
So since you're paying more,
you're getting a worse deal.
So it's pretty obvious that if you want to discount this number two more than
100 and 105 why's going to have to be less than 7% okay?
So that's the first thing we said.
Now what did he do?
He gave a number and he said seven over
mmm.
Seven over 105 which he said was about 6.7%
yeah.
Okay.
So that number that he gave is called,
the current is called the,
uh,
current yield
nother number people gate give.
Okay.
And he figured that was 6.7%.
So let's believe him that 6.7%.
Okay.
Now,
okay.
So,
and the,
okay.
How does that number compare to the yield?
To maturity.
Okay.
To why.
Well,
we could compute this out.
Oh,
on Xcel since I'm doing so brilliantly at it now.
Um,
oh,
okay.
So we could go,
you know,
seven,
seven
and 107.
Okay.
Those are our payments.
And then we could try some yield to maturity in general,
rate of return,
internal rate of return.
And let's call it,
that's gas 1.067.
Okay.
And now we'd say that the present,
the cashflows is going to be,
this is going to be the left.
Uh,
oh dear.
I have to number things.
So again,
there's probably some clever way of doing this.
So this'll be,
I forgot the,
to write the year.
Okay,
thanks.
so this is,
let's just go into,
let's just add this,
uh,
equals up plus Hunter Hayes.
And I'm just going to copy this.
All right.
So now I have numbered all the years
equals up plus one enter and now control copy.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I've numbered all the years here and here are the payments.
And now at this,
at this a yield to maturity,
I'm going to go equal the thing on the left divided by the,
uh,
yield to maturity that we're guessing.
MMM.
Hi.
Uh,
raise to this power.
Okay.
And now I can just copy that and I've got all these cash flows.
What did I do that time?
Control copy.
Sorry.
Right.
So I just want a copy of this.
Oh,
I see.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
Okay.
So I have to hear,
I've got the,
the uh,
your rights I've got,
okay.
So there's a trick here,
which I forgot,
which is that Eight v,
the discount rate,
the internal rate of return.
He,
I haven't got to put a dollar sign.
Dollar e dollar one.
So that way it remembers the spot.
Okay.
So now I want to copy it.
It's going to remember that.
Okay.
What's B One?
Perfect.
Oh B one.
Thank you.
So are two mistakes
me?
One.
Okay.
He's so now control copy.
Yeah.
So I'm supposed to be showing you how easy it is to do this,
but uh,
all right.
So anyway,
that's it.
So you see for each number here,
I've got the payments for every year and I've discounted them by taking this
internal rate of return.
Okay?
And now I just have to sum all this
e equals some.
Um,
oh shit.
I'm trying to sound like you're right.
So C,
okay,
so here equals I want to sum all these.
So what did I do wrong?
C One Colon,
say 10.
That's what I thought I did,
but obviously I didn't.
Okay,
good.
And now we can do this and the square it.
Okay.
So that's the thing I want to minimize.
And so now I'm going to tools solver.
Men,
man,
see 12 by concentrating on this number.
Okay.
And solve,
all right,
what did I do?
Here's this song,
here's the scoop,
all the original price.
[inaudible] thank you very much.
Okay,
so we need the original price was 105.
Very good.
And so I see the preparing,
this would have helped.
Okay,
so here's the sum.
So he just summed all these things.
Okay.
And here we're going to,
um,
uh,
all right,
let's just,
okay,
so we're summing those rights.
So I summed all these and then I've got the original price Hun.
105 and tear,
okay,
now we'll add equals this.
MMM.
Plus.
Okay.
Okay,
you're right.
Okay.
This minus that.
And now we want to square this equals up,
squared and,
and now we'll do solver.
Hopefully there isn't another mistake.
Okay,
so
tools solver.
Um,
okay,
so I want lat times a one.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's very bad.
Okay.
Anyway,
you can solve it using solar and it's extremely simple to do.
And a child could learn how to do it.
Okay?
So we get solver and we solve all this.
Um,
and you're,
you should be able to use XL with no problem at all.
So,
um,
okay,
so the question is what are the relationships between the current yield and the
yield to maturity?
And suppose there some actual interest rate.
So there's an actual market interest rate,
market interest rate,
um,
say you know,
6% or something.
Okay.
So those are the things that we want to sort out now in the next five minutes.
So I'll let me go back to the notes and we'll re ask all the questions here.
I can see that solver.
I brokens
yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So,
okay,
so let's,
um,
so suppose that the right actual interest rate in the economy
then our bond,
the bond that was seven,
seven,
107.
If the actual interest rate was say 6%.
Okay.
The price of the bond would be more than a hundred.
So some price,
which will be the present value will be greater than a hundred,
obviously because it's paying.
If it were it,
if the price is only if the interest rate's only 6%,
this is giving you more than a hundred.
Now the current yield
is,
uh,
seven over the present value.
Exactly what analogous to what he said.
Okay,
so if you,
if someone calls you on the phone,
you haven't gotten these calls yet,
but when you get older you'll get,
unless you,
you know their their screen now.
So it's harder to get these,
but it used to be a few years ago,
you get called on the phone quite often and somebody would say he's running a
bond fund and the bond fund is really doing great.
Anyone's to tell you that the bonds they have in the fun last year paid a
current yield of seven over the present value,
which is much bigger than the interest rate of 6% and therefore you should buy
his bonds.
Okay.
Now what can you say about that?
Suppose somebody tells you there's a market price for the bonds.
Okay.
Which we know is the present value at the interest rate of 6% and he tells you
that,
look,
look at the market value I got last year for these,
the yield,
I got the current yield I got on these bonds,
the present value,
once you know some number bigger than a hundred but I take seven over a hundred
over the present value and I get something bigger than 6% at your bank,
you're only getting 6% so therefore it,
you know you shouldn't invest in my fun.
So why is that?
I mean is that a good argument to invest in his fund?
Why not?
Okay,
now this bond is called a premium bond
because the price
is bigger than the face.
No discount bond
means the price is less than the face
and a power bond.
The price equals the face.
So
just because a bond pays a coupon of seven it may be when the bond was issued,
everybody thought the interest rate was going to be 7% forever.
So that's why they pick the coupon of seven and that's,
and the,
so that the price when they first issued it would be equal to its face value,
but you know,
maybe the next day,
so it's still a 10 year bond.
Practically no time has changed,
but unexpectedly the interest rates fell to 6% if you take the same coupon bond
paying seven all the time at 6% interest,
it's now it's,
it's price is obviously going to go up in the market because everybody is going
to discount the seven's,
not at 7% but at 6% and get a number that's bigger than a hundred okay,
so you're going to have to pay more for the bond because the,
you know,
the present value is higher.
However,
people who now will try and market the bond,
they're going to tell you,
well look at the market price,
whatever the market price is.
So this is the current yield is the market price.
Okay.
They'll say,
look at the market price.
This is what we bought the bonds for.
You know,
I'm a fond,
I went out and bought these bonds for present value,
you know,
and I now look at the price I paid and I got $7 for these bonds,
this year in income and seven over the market price of the bond is bigger than
6% so I was doing a great job.
You should invest in my fun.
Okay.
So that can't be a correct thing to say or a persuasive thing to say because the
market price reflected the fact that the interest rate for 6% everybody was
properly computing the present value.
And let's say the market price was equal to the present value.
Present value would indeed be a greater than a hundred and in fact the market
price would be the,
the,
the current yield would be more than the interest rate of 6%.
So why is that?
So I claim seven also theorem.
If,
uh,
if
market price
price equals present value
at,
uh,
going interest rate,
van
high yield
on a premium bond
is always greater radar,
then the interest and the interest rate.
Okay.
So why is that?
So in this case,
if I hadn't screwed up the XL,
we would have calculating the present value.
Okay.
So seven,
seven,
107,
there was only a 6% interest.
So everybody taught by Irving Fisher computes the new present value,
which of course is bigger than a hundred and that's the market price.
Some unscrupulous salesmen,
uh,
starts a fund,
buys the bond for whatever this present value of the market prices.
Then goes out to a bunch of clients,
potential clients,
investors,
and says,
look,
my very first year in business I spent,
you know,
a little more than a hundred dollars and I got $7 as a coupon and seven over
this.
You know,
little more than a hundred is giving me,
obviously occurring that he's giving me a current year that's more than 6%.
I beat the interest rate.
You should invest in me.
And by the way,
I'll charge you a little fee to do that because I'm doing so great now.
That's always going to be the case.
So it has to be that he really hasn't accomplished anything at all.
So why is it easy to see that whenever I computed the present value,
it was going to have to be more than this.
Current yield would always be more than 6% how do I know that?
Yup.
Perfect.
Relatively higher.
It's going to mean to your original face though.
Exactly.
So let's say to keep this simpler,
let's oppose,
these were tens everywhere.
Okay.
And the interest rate went down to 5%
okay.
Now what's going to be the present value of this bond?
It's not going to be 200 if,
if,
if the bond paid 10 10
uh,
okay.
Suppose I have something paying 10 10 10 and 110 and the coupon is 5% what is
the present value of this?
Like lame,
present value?
It's going to be less than 200 the coupon is always double the interest rate.
Okay.
So looks like,
you know,
that's what you'd get if you had $200 but at the end is he saying you're only
going to get 110 and not 210 so this present value of this thing has to be less
than 200 okay.
So if you double the coupon,
if you,
if you have the interest rate,
the interest rate was originally 10% here.
If you cut the interest rate in half to 5% it looks like your annual coupon is
double the interest rate.
But at the end you don't get a principal that's double the original principal.
All you did was double,
you know,
relative to the interest rate of 5% the coupons twice as big as you'd normally
expect,
but the face isn't.
So therefore this has to be worth less than 200 if it were a,
you know,
205% would give you 10 0101010210 okay.
But this gives you 10,
10,
ten one hundred ten.
So obviously the present value is less than five,
less than 200 but therefore 10 over something less than 200 is going to be more
than 5% okay?
So that's his intuitive proof,
which is the essence of the thing that if ever you have a coupon bond who's,
that's a premium bond,
then the current yield is always above the,
uh,
current yield is always above the interest rate.
So you can always advertise it as having a spectacular,
um,
current yield,
when in fact,
it's just priced perfectly fairly.
Okay.
So I'm going to just continue the story of what's the right way to measure
things and how you can get confused by measuring the wrong way.
Next class.